this is one thing we're going to we're
asking
companies uh you have to force behaviors
and at Black Rock we are forcing
behaviors here's Black Rock CEO uh
explaining that uh yes they are using
forces and economic levers to promote
all of these bad ideas using ESG take a
look behaviors are going to have to
change and this is one thing we're going
to we're asking
companies uh you have to force behaviors
and at Black Rock we are forcing beh
behaviors what we are doing internally
is if you don't achieve these levels of
impact your compensation going to be
impacted okay you have to force
behaviors and if you don't force
behaviors whether it's gender or race or
just any way you want to say the
composition of your
team you're going to be
impacted I mean I can't even imagine
anything more evil why do you have to
force
behaviors Connor when you take your
whiteness when you leave this place and
you think about your white I'm not
forcing you to do it it would be nice if
you would evaluate your whiteness and
your white privilege Phoenix you too I
know you have a little darker skin but
still little something would be nice but
I'm not going to force you to what is he
talking about we at Black Rock so what
they do with ESG is they tell these
giant corporations that you must have a
certain amount of black people and a
certain amount of and a certain
amount of people with limps and lesbians
and give me a who is a little
confused about something and build your
team and then ly because you don't do it
on skill you actually put something
instead instead of skill and quality and
and and worth and hard work and
dedication instead of focusing on that
meritocracy you then build worse
products and that's why all the Disney
movies suck that's why Disney is purging
money right now that's why the santis
purely beat Disney absolutely did beat
Disney